oh
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
foreign
hello hello whoa hot mike
good evening welcome to the table my
name is karen it is so good to see all
of your faces here tonight
and welcome to those of you that are
online as well we're so glad you're here
i just have a few announcements i
actually have three
whole announcements tonight which is a
little more than we usually have but
we've got some cool stuff coming up here
at the table at places and and events
where you can be involved
the first one and i brought my notes
because it's been a while since i've
done announcements and i don't want to
miss i don't want to miss any
important details so the first event we
have coming up is a volunteer
opportunity that's happening next
saturday at the five loaves food pantry
here in saxi
we are going to be helping them out for
a couple hours just from 10 a.m to noon
on saturday
we're going to be hanging clothes
putting together snack bags
separating food for them for the food
pantry it's just a great opportunity to
contribute to our broader community and
be a part and help them out this is a
really busy season for them so anything
that we can do to help them out so that
they can help others in our community we
want to do that so if you are interested
and you're available next saturday from
10 a.m to noon it's just a couple hours
out of your day i'll be there i'd love
to see you you can either text brett
directly or you can see brett or me
after the service let us know that
you're interested and we'll get you
scheduled for that
secondly
i am super excited about a new meetup
that's launching here at the table for
those of you you that don't know meetups
are our small groups here and we have a
teen meetup that is launching at the
beginning of the year for our kids who
are 7th through 12th grades
guys girls anywhere on the gender
spectrum they are welcome and maggie is
going to be leading that and she's
putting together a great team
that will be launching in the new year
however they're going to be doing a
christmas gathering that will be sunday
let me make sure i get the date right
sunday december 5th immediately after
the service
so teens if you're interested or if you
have a teen or know a team that might
want to do this
bring them to church and then hang out
they can hang out after the service for
a gathering
um so save the date for that and then
lastly
can you believe that i think christmas
is in 40 days
my daughter just told me for gift
gifting purposes
christmas is in 40 days which means
christmas eve service which is a staple
here at the table and we will be having
our christmas eve service no shock on
december 24th
you're welcome
so pencil that in we'll give you exact
time and other details for that as it
gets closer but just so you know yes we
will do a christmas eve service and it
will be fabulous and fun and festive
all right so with that said how about if
we take a moment to just
breathe decompress from your day from
your week whatever
you walked in here with
take a breath
you were welcome here you were loved
here
we're glad you're here and jesus meets
you here so let's pray
god
thank you for tonight thank you for the
table that is nothing without the people
here and nothing without you god
so help us to remember that just simple
jesus you and the people around us the
people we're in relationship with
help us to be present
help us to center on you tonight god
help us to hear
with our minds and our hearts whatever
it is you want to speak to us tonight
help us to remember that we are loved
and we're not alone
and we're in this together
in jesus name amen
amen
thank you karen i know i needed that too
just a moment to recenter y'all it's
been kind of a crazy rehearsal leading
up to tonight so we have this great new
sound system which has been such a gift
but it also comes with new challenges
when you're trying to tweak and fix
things and learn how to fix things
so
i'm coming back to that simple truth
that we've talked about before we are
friends singing songs to god in a room
together that's what we're doing tonight
and i just invite you guys into that
space with us it's not always perfect
and it probably will not be tonight um
but it's not about that it's about us
having an opportunity to offer our
hearts to god so why don't you guys
stand up with us gary's going to get us
started
and as always i invite you to enter in
with your whole self um so clapping um
if you would like raising your hands or
sitting and reflecting all acceptable in
this space your whole self is welcome
and sing loud and sing loud i love that
coming from the back row and carter says
something you better listen all right
this guy doesn't he doesn't mess around
all right let's see here
[Music]
clouds
i will not forget you
you're
[Music]
and my sacrifice is
not what you can give
but what i alone can
[Music]
loud song i see
me
[Music]
with a thankful heart i
mean my offering
and my sacrifices
not what you can't give
but what i alone can
give to
[Music]
huge
for you
[Music]
i will not forget you
i will not forget
yeah
[Music]
with
and my
sacrifices
not what you can
[Music]
give to you
a prayer by desmond
tutu victory is ours
goodness is stronger than evil
love is stronger than hate
light is stronger than darkness
life is stronger than death
victory is ours through him who loves us
[Music]
in
worship giving all i am
to seek your face
[Music]
my whole life i placed in your hands
god of mercy
[Music]
at your throne
and you came to my rescue and died
[Music]
where you are
your face
[Music]
your
at your throne
you answer
[Music]
i wanna be
where you
are
[Music]
rescue and died
we praise you
god tonight
we love you
feel your presence
[Music]
in my life
hi
[Music]
be lifted by our love
be lifted
is
[Music]
[Applause]
be lifted
[Music]
me
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
do
[Music]
cycle
you answered
and
[Music]
just the voices
i
called
you answered
and you came to my rescue and
[Music]
would you guys join in as we go into the
prayer of the people
and karen will be reading out loud for
anyone who would like to join us online
with their comments
for the city of saxi texas and for every
city and community and all of those who
live in them
we pray to you
for the good earth that you have given
us and the wisdom and the will to
conserve it
we pray to you
for those who travel on land sea or air
for the old and the sick for the widow
and the orphan for the injured and the
suffering
we pray to you for the poor and the
oppressed and the unemployed and the
destitute
for the prisoners and the captives and
for all who remember and care for them
we pray to you lord we know that you
love us
and that you hear us so now we lift
these names and situations
up to you
[Music]
angelina
from online nancy's chemo treatments
karen
and those struggling with physical or
emotional pain
nicki's hip pain
[Music]
for those without families
for these names and moments that we've
spoken aloud and for those that we've
kept in our heart we pray to you that
they may have life and light
healing and hope
peace and a deep sense of your presence
[Music]
with no point of reference
you spoke to the dark and fleshed out
the wonder of light
[Music]
and as you speak
a hundred billion
galaxies are born
[Music]
i can see your heart in everything
creation seeks
[Music]
god of your promises
for once you have spoken
your nature in science follows the sound
of your
[Music]
voice a hundred billion creatures
if it all
[Music]
if creation still obeys you so
alive
[Music]
is
worship so alive
[Music]
so
the wind goes
[Music]
silence is
god of salvation
[Music]
the light of the world abandoned in
darkness to die
and as you speak
[Music]
so i could find
you've done
[Music]
precious
desire
[Music]
jesus thank you for seeing us
when we're the one that has gone off on
our own
even when we've turned our back
and walked away
you see us
you stay with us
you call us back
you invite us to your path of life
you heal us
you know us
and god we want to offer that same life
to the world around us
god would we choose the way of jesus
the path that others forget
or turn away from
would we choose love
would we choose forgiveness
would we choose hope
because just like caitlyn was reading
earlier god
love
is stronger life is stronger light is
stronger
god would we choose you you are stronger
than what we face
you are stronger than the pain of this
world
we lean into that tonight god
we thank you for your grace
we ask for more of it in our lives god
thanks for loving us
it's in jesus name we pray
amen
you guys can be seated and turn and say
hello to someone around you as brett
comes up to share the message
all right
all right all right
there we go good evening everybody
um
well it's uh really really wonderful to
be with you oh i know we're
so thanks for your grace and can we give
this team a hand because they're doing a
really good job
i'm i'm very very grateful for such a
small community we really have an
amazing tech team i mean
it's
yeah we're really really blessed so um
all right well i want to um just welcome
all of you tonight and
um it's just great to be with you and
that of course includes um those joining
us online we love you lots and and
everyone who might be new here kind of
you know starting to check it out or
find your place and um it can take a lot
of courage to go through those double
doors so um thank you for for being uh
with us tonight i hope you feel a sense
of um welcome
uh so we are in
a series on first peter um we titled it
first peter part one because we're only
gonna make it through chapter one before
the christmas season of advent hits uh
so we'll have to kind of hit the pause
button do some advent stuff and then
we'll come back to first peter chapter
two so we're gonna um over the next two
weeks we'll wrap up though this this
first chapter of first peter so um
tonight we are in verses 13 through 16.
um so if you want to go ahead and follow
along either in your bibles or it's on
the screen
as usual so let's read along therefore
peter writes with minds that are alert
and fully sober
set your hope on the grace to be brought
to you when jesus christ is revealed at
his coming
as obedient children do not conform to
the evil desires you had when you lived
in ignorance
but just as he who called you is holy
so be holy in all you do for it is
written be holy because i am holy
so the title of my message tonight uh if
you're a note taker you can jot this
down is disordered um desires disordered
desires and i'm gonna be kind of very
focused in on verse 14 that we just read
which has this language of um evil
desires
i think this is a somewhat misunderstood
uh concept so that's kind of what i want
to really unpack tonight um is is kind
of that phrase um and before i give you
kind of my big idea i should give a nod
to saint augustine
who um very helped me with this idea of
uh
evil desires as a disordered desire so
uh here's the big idea
for tonight that we'll be kind of
unpacking my problem is not
desire itself
but disordered desire
loves and passions and urges
all running amok
and ruining my life that's kind of like
the uh the big idea for tonight um i've
been
coaching a soccer team
now
for a while
i don't know how i got into this well i
know how the
league emails you when your team doesn't
have a coach and they kind of basically
haggle the parents until someone steps
up so it was like many seasons ago i
kind of stepped up to do this and i
thought i got out of the job because we
joined a new team because the poor team
i was coaching back in the day with my
my oldest son dax
we just lost so much so it was kind of
like time to phase that team out we
heard of another team we could join so
we did he had a friend playing in a
different league you know in garland so
we joined the garland soccer association
so i was the assistant coach last year
that's really my place
i didn't grow up playing soccer uh so
everything i learned is from watching on
television and youtube
so i'm very much that guy so last year i
was the assistant coach um but then the
head coach moved to arlington he's like
well
she's yours
run with it and so here i am head
coaching again and we actually had a
good season not because i'm an amazing
coach we just have some good players so
you know especially this age you don't
need like genius strategy it's like get
that ball in there go and you know we
got some kids that can do it so
it's been a good season um but you know
i must admit i'm grateful uh one way
they kind of set up gsa sets of the
field is that
like i'm here kind of with my team on
one side of the field and then all of
the parents
are on the other side of the field and
this is good because i don't know if
you've been into youth sports at all i
mean maybe
maybe it's just it's i don't know if
it's just this kind of garland sexy
rowlet
surely it's all over the country right
it's just complete madness and people
just losing their minds over these
children planes i mean it's
it is it's weird the psychology of it
how parents start to buy and like feel
like it's them on the field or all their
hopes and dreams i mean it's it's a lot
right so i'm grateful that i'm kind of
over here um
but i must admit i mean overall this
season's been pretty good we have good
parents you know um
but
we had a funny kind of experience with
um so there was this one team and uh we
i remember when i was assistant coaching
we lost to them three times last year
apparently we've lost to them every year
even before we joined the team like we
just they're just a good team you know
and sometimes sometimes it's just a good
team you just get get beat and so we had
played them
i think twice this year already had lost
twice so this is like two weeks ago
we're playing them for the third time
our team's gotten better um and honestly
i mean i don't mind like you know we're
good teams we win some some but this
team this is a tough team to lose to
because um
it's because they're coach
he's just like he's that guy who's kind
of crossed the line from i went to win
to i have genuine anger issues
and it just all comes i mean he's just
the crazy it's just the crazy so intense
you just screaming just losing it so
this is like it's just one of those
teams that you really like you want to
beat you know like it's just like oh my
gosh you're driving me crazy and um in
fact we had a lady she's um she i think
she immigrated from uh some eastern
european country i'm not sure which one
like years ago and she came up to me
before the game she's like are we
playing that team saturday and i was
like we are she's like
oh i want to win them
i want to win them so bad i was like i
want to win them too
i want to win and the reason we want to
win them is because this coach so y'all
so two saturdays ago right before
halloween we are we're playing them and
right i mean within a minute we score
one and nothing
like five minutes later we score again
two to nothing we score again three to
nothing like we're just we're just
taking it to him and i mean my smile's
getting bigger and bigger and all of a
sudden i notice down because the parents
are all over there but the coaches right
we stand across
and i can hear this guy and he is losing
his mind
he's i mean he i look at him and he has
a vein like he looks like he's about to
have a heart attack i mean he's just
popping out he is freaking out suddenly
we score again four to nothing and the
reason we score is because one of their
defenders basically made a mistake he's
pretty clearly he was new you know and
this guy literally no joke this coach
looks at him he yells out he says
you are playing like crap and i am this
close to pulling you out of the game i
mean he's just he's losing now did i
mention this is ten-year-old soccer
tenure now um
what is going on there what i want to
suggest to you tonight is what the
problem with this coach um is that he
has he has a problem of disordered
desire
because like on the one hand like
there's something to him right he wants
inside of him he wants to win
you know he wants to end that's not bad
like he wants to um he wants to probably
feel good about himself too
and these are not
desires that in and of themselves are
like evil how dare you want self-esteem
or how dare you want to win you know
like that's
that's not terrible or something but
what happens the problem is when it gets
disordered when when all of a sudden
that desire to win that desire to i've
got to feel good i've got to feel
validated when all of a sudden as a
coach you can't let that desire be
elevated above
the well-being of your players
right can you see how
and this is where i think we kind of
misunderstand disorder or evil desire
you hear that phrase i don't know
anything like drugs or whatever random
kind of thus in you know
um
and actually this is where augustine's
so insightful is he says well it's not
it's often not about just the thing
itself in fact rarely you know most
desires like have some biological need i
mean even you know think of all sorts of
addictions like why do we go to those
it's often because we have some
emotional need it's you know so
augustine would say it's not so much the
problem is not just the desire itself
like oh how dare you have desire your
evil desires he would say
the problem is disordered desire
right in other words it's the exact
thing we name my problem is not desire
itself its disorder desire its loves and
its passions and its urges all running
amok and ruining my life
um i think another um
desire this i talked about this on july
4th
one of my more uncomfortable sermons
i've ever preached it wasn't it was we
actually joined with pleasant valley the
church true space we went we joined with
them uh so i preached it there but it
was all about um
the idea of love for one's country you
know this is a real trick for christians
is is like love of country and like what
do how do we do this right because is it
bad to love one's country
no
why is it bad to love one's home well no
of course not but but what happens
there and it's i mean it's probably it's
human nature you know we're tribal
people like we love i told maggie that's
one reason back to the sports thing this
is one reason we love sports it's almost
like this purely tribal thing you just
get to be a tribe for a while you know
us against them come on but hopefully
it's in good fun right so what happens
though when it's on the level of a
country
right well there's can be something very
powerful about a sense of we and
connectedness we're all in this together
we're all american you know kind of the
the vibe and that can be there can be a
good desire in that in terms of we do we
need tribes we need connectedness and we
need a sense of home that's like
important stuff but what happens we've
seen this play out in history right like
when that desire gets elevated to the
highest place
what happens oh my god i mean it's just
world war ii anyone like it's just it's
hell on earth and even not even just to
play out in such a big way but just even
um
versus individuals i mean
we kind of start getting kind of
elevating that to the highest place and
suddenly we can find ourselves thinking
things saying things about people who
aren't kind of from our tribe or our
country like we never would have dreamed
like five years ago 10 years ago we
wouldn't have been there but but what
happens like all of a sudden we shock
ourselves because that that desire gets
elevated to the highest
place
what is its disordered desire
i was thinking um
to kind of bring it into the the home
you know this is something i struggle
with i like
um i'm a bit of a hobbit like just
personally i'm like introvert and i just
want quiet you know
and so i was thinking of parents you
know who maybe just want like peace and
quiet and order
you know order in the home i grew up my
um mom who's here by the way my mom and
dad are they're awesome
are here and they my mom raised me on
musicals
has anyone seen that oh the old one uh
sound of music's like the classic you
know yeah um and that's like remember
the the guy the uh the captain or
whatever his his i haven't seen in gosh
20 years so sorry if i'm vague on the
details but remember he like he's this
scene if you've seen the movie like he
has all these children he's like blowing
a whistle because he's like a ship
captain or somebody's in the navy so
he's kind of trying to run the household
like the military you know he says
he has signals whistle signals for the
children to come in right
um and i think we obviously don't i
don't do that in my house but i am
someone who likes order you know i mean
it's like obedience people it's like the
li it's time for the lights to be out
right now and i don't want your
questions you know it's just like come
on it's nine o'clock i'm dying here and
no um you guys are like oh gosh he does
have problems i do i struggle with
disorder desire because
now is that like bad you know to want
peace and quiet order or schedule or no
anything this isn't these aren't bad
desires and what
until they get elevated to the highest
place
and i've um
remember visiting friends and like being
in homes where that kind of desire for
like obedience and order
it like just a chill
can just settle over the whole home you
experienced this maybe
it's ju i guess and it can kill
love it can stifle any sense of care
and you can be defensive right what are
you what are you saying that uh we don't
need obedience in this house you know
you can see how you can defend it by
saying well the desire is a good desire
we need this you know it's like well
yeah
but you can't elevate it to the highest
place
it's like a good coach doesn't elevate
that desire over his players or her
players right it's similar with
parenting i was thinking even um
kind of career so i was this is maybe 15
years ago i was 23 years old
and um i was working in a corporate job
and i had a side gig on this we started
a company with some friends and i had a
side gig and so i was working a lot
i would wake up i'd work on the company
go to my other job my real job work on
that at lunch break work on the new
company
go back to my job
in the evenings work on the new company
you know it's kind of this was my
schedule just doing a lot
and so i was talking with a guy at this
um this this this corporate world that i
was in and a co-worker his name was kirk
and he was a good man he was like a
christian
probably 15 years older than me at that
time
and uh well-respected you know and so i
was chatting with him and i think
looking back i think
maybe there was something in me that i
was a little bit i was kind of looking
for validation you know and maybe i
don't know maybe i was proud of myself
for like working hard or whatever i
don't know so i'm like chatting with him
and i'm kind of sharing with him my
schedule
you know
and
i expected him to pat me on the back but
this is i was shocked when this is the
only thing he said he just said this he
said so when do you see your family
i mean it was like a sucker punch i did
not see this coming
like
now what was he named is having a career
bad no
is having a side hustle bad no
but can it become a disordered desire
oh absolutely
when it gets elevated to the highest
place and all of a sudden this is the
thing
this like this is the priority this is
the desire that orders all my other
desires this is the thing and so
everyone else in my life can kind of
take second third place perhaps even a
spouse or children close friends right
you can see where this goes
right this is i think what peter's
getting at i think this is what
augustine's getting at with the our
problem as human beings is um it's a
problem of um of desire of all of man we
do don't we like because desire touches
everything if you think about it like we
wouldn't get out of bed in the morning
if we don't desire
so we are deeply actually get in a
minute to a james k smith quote where he
talks like we are just
um
we are desiring
creatures
like this is we think we're thinking
things
that's kind of the story modernity has
kind of told us the last few hundred
years like to be human is to be we're
the thinkers we're the rational
creatures we're the you know smith says
nah
no we're like the lovers we're the we're
the desiring creatures we just want want
want wan want want
and that's kind of the beauty of us
because we can love well and desire well
but it's also our absolute downfall
right because we just get all out of
whack and
we lose our priorities and we're sort of
like a river desire sort of like a
raging river that sort of overruns its
banks right channeled it can be powerful
and good and beautiful but boy when it
runs those over those banks
it's like a disaster okay so that's sort
of the problem this of course begs like
what on earth is the solution how do we
how do i fix desire i don't know i kill
it or just murder desire you know um
i want to say no instead let's come back
to our text verse 14 as obedient
children peter wrote do not conform to
the evil desires you had when you lived
in ignorance
in other words
before following christ
whether it's like the coach who just
wants to win at all costs or the parent
who's like order or you know career
whatever it is but the desires are kind
of running amok so he's like before you
understood what desire was all about
before you kind of ordered them
you lived in ignorance verse 15 but just
as he who called you is holy
so be holy in all you do for it is
written be holy because i am holy that's
a quote by the way from leviticus 19 2
be holy because i am holy it's
interesting there that that um that
language of or that phrase is really
rooting the idea of holiness in god's
very being in essence it's not just like
a side thing but it's like be this is
who god is saying this is who i am so
this is who you as the people of god who
you are called um to be
um now i understand
this word holiness i don't know how does
it strike i'm kind of i wish i could
have like a little five-minute convo
with each of you out in the back like
just to ask so i say holiness
and how does that hit you you know um
holiness
holy maybe for some of you it's like a
new word
um so you're like i have no idea should
i be feeling something right now um
maybe others of you or even as i read
the verse maybe even in the very opening
it's like holy be holy as i'm holy
you're called to holiness holy living
it's just like oh my gosh i can't do
this you know um
i think you probably many of you will
understand that brand
holiness
it's taken a hit
in recent years
i think because holiness at least in the
church has tended to get untethered from
love
you know so you had people who are like
quote unquote holy
but they were like real jerks
right weren't very loving
um
so they didn't i don't know whatever the
sins were they didn't
smoke the cigarettes or you know drink
too much or what i don't know whatever
the things were they didn't wear the
short shorts or i don't know whatever
these ideas of holiness of people right
they didn't do that
and yet they were like flat-out unkind
unloving people and yet everyone was
like there that's the ideal that's be
that they are doing it there you know
and we got i think messed up in our
understanding of like holiness like what
are we
talking about so i want to in light of
kind of what i've shared about desire i
want to give a little bit of like a new
definition a new kind of image of
holiness so the path to holiness
is the path by god's grace of ordering
and orienting my desires
that's what it's about so in other words
it's not about um killing desire
right or becoming someone who like i
just don't want anything
i don't desire anything i don't know
this is maybe
pietistic brett of like seventh grade
who just like i don't want anything but
god you know it's kind of like well okay
little buddy
um that's sort of a good idea or maybe
or it sounds good but in the end like we
have to live life and life is not about
or holiness is not just about oh i just
don't want anything at all in life you
know like no no what holiness is um
it's you might actually think of it as
um
well actually let me read let me let me
read this i think maybe a good way to
think of it is jesus talked about
ordering and like what do we prioritize
i think that's actually a good way to
think of it
so he said i'm going to read a message
paraphrase of this to give it kind of
fresh language this is matthew 22 jesus
said love the lord your god
with all your passion all your prayer
all your intelligence this is the most
important the first on any list but
there's a second to set alongside it
love others as well as you love yourself
these two commands they are pegs
everything in god's law and the prophets
in other words the vast majority of the
old testament everything hangs from
them you might say then that that
holiness it's about
prioritizing my love for god
my love for people and if you go back
through and think of all the examples i
shared right and we covered a lot of
them from career stuff to
soccer coaching youth sports you know to
family to like where do we get
disoriented where do things go haywire
it's when we miss those two as the most
important things
right that's and that's what holiness is
is actually saying look i'm very clear
on my priorities i want to love god with
everything in my being i love this uh
eugene peterson paraphrase of this of
all of my passion and my prayer and my
intelligence like my whole being i want
to love god and then i want to love
others just as much as i love myself
which does include a lovely jesus
assumes we're going to love ourselves
and that right like that's
that's the priorities and then i allow
that to order and orient everything else
in my life in other words if i'm
desiring something but it's up ending
and wreaking havoc
in those areas
right it's causing me to hate myself
it's causing me to hate other people
it's eliminated or eroding any love or
prioritization of god
it's a problem right that's what
holiness is about not just like don't
chew the tobacco you know it's such a i
don't know shallow understanding of you
know holiness
um yeah so here's the the smith quote
i love this james k smith um
i think he's really one of the best
christian writers writing today he's
excellent he says this jesus is a
teacher who doesn't just inform our
intellect
but he forms our very loves
he isn't content to simply deposit new
ideas into your mind he is after nothing
less than your wants your loves and your
longings
i love that i i think that's just so
insightful for what like what are we
actually doing here
you ever wonder that like coming to
church like why am
why are we here
what are we doing is this weird that we
all come here and you know sing songs
like
we what are we doing i think this is a
beautiful reminder of like this is the
journey we're on
this is the journey we're on see
actually holiness is not some icky
religious weird term holiness really is
about becoming a whole person
we might call an integrated person
someone that has yes all the desires of
what it means to be human
and yet
instead of running amok in ruining our
life and raging like a river that's out
of control instead they're just oriented
and pointed kind of towards true north
oriented towards god
towards others towards even a healthy
self understanding self-love and and
then everything just kind of starts to
fall into place and church is the
community where we can get honest about
how that's going beautifully
and uh how it's maybe not going so
beautifully you know
like that's
i think that's some of what we're doing
here
so in closing i want to give you three
kind of implications three kind of a
little something a little more practical
since i realize this could be a bit
maybe abstract so three implications of
this first because god and desire touch
every part of my life
christian spirituality will ultimately
do the same
because god and desire touch every part
of my life christian spirituality will
ultimately do the same
um
you know it's easy well as we mentioned
desire kind of touches everything
um from you know money to sexuality to
um
parenting coaching youth sports playing
youth sport i mean just the whole gamut
um but it's easy for us in kind of the
modern world to try to do this thing of
separating kind of teasing apart like
where's my spiritual life
and then there's like my real life
you know they're sort of like the
god and then like you know the secular
or whatever kind of view have you all
kind of tracking with how we do this you
know we tease these apart i think
because desire touches everything
because god touches everything
our christian walk is going to have to
do the same right there's no teasing
these apart is this back to smith's
quote of how jesus is very interested in
reshaping and forming all of our loves
and our wants and our desires like the
whole thing so that basically means oh
wow god's like after my whole life you
know um and that but that's good news
because honestly it's
it's really painful
to
not
live with rightly ordered desires like
it's oh gosh it'll take you to hell
you know like hell on earth oh i see um
addicts i worked with the homeless for
many years and oh my god
like you know where they can just take
you
just to absolute health so this is um i
think really is this beautiful right
this isn't like oh gosh god's after me
he's after my whole life my loves and my
wants and my longings oh no like no no
no that is good news
it's good news to be ordered in that way
um second implication is that loving
christ is more caught via habits
practices spiritual disciplines than
taught via books lectures and sermons
that last one was hard for me to write
but it's true
um like i was thinking about um well
really the last few hundred years
christians have been very obsessed with
information
like that's you want to be discipled you
want to follow jesus what you need is
the right information you know the right
theology all the exact bible verses um
and just to be clear i mean if you've
been around the table you know we're far
from like being anti-intellectual or
something we're checking we don't want
to check our brains at the door um
so
it that matters right idea because we
live from kind of ideas and stories and
so thinking that matters
um
but ultimately like i said earlier we're
not so much like thinking things
we're desiring creatures
and because of this well we all know we
can know the right thing
the problem is
doing it
correct
right like i know what to do in my life
my problem is my desires are running
amok and ruining everything right and i
think this is where christian we've
gotten a little off track because we
thought if i just get the right info
even you see kind of a secular version
of this and folks who read a lot of
self-help books
can be kind of similar passion or like
almost an addiction to like i just i
just need the right the breakthrough if
i can just get the right if i can just
watch the right youtube video
that will then i'll get it because then
i got the right info and it's like it'll
unlock my whole life and then i can do
everything i'm called to do you know
it's like
probably not
because it's often not about more
information it's like about our it's
about our living
um
so for example i could we could do just
to pick a random topic like we could
talk about submission to god that could
be i don't know like a sermon series on
you know following god's will for your
life or something
and i could man we could do an
eight-week series on it we could do book
study we could look at all of the
phrases in the bible that say submit to
god and we could look at it in hebrew
and in greek and all the things
and and that would matter like i'm not
trying to downplay that like that could
matter that could be helpful you might
get some new angles on it you know
understand it more um
you know would be even more powerful
is if you woke up each morning
and you got out of your bed and you
bowed down low
and you opened up your hands
and you said god
i
am yours
i am yours
move through me today
speak through me today
i don't want to say anything except what
you want me to say i don't want to do
anything
except what you're calling me to do
help me god
what is that
that's a practice
right and even the bowing low
matters
why because we're embodied creatures
like it just this is what's so weird it
just it it's more caught
than taught
it just kind of gets into you this is
actually why i think church matters
because we can talk all day god is love
god is this god you know but it's
another thing to actually come into a
space and like connect
and feel it
and live it
experience it
right it's powerful um why is that
because this is about because it's about
desire it's not just about info
you know
um you can get info from a podcast
but it's different when you start living
it i think um
for example this is why something like
fasting
kind of actually matters right for us in
the west this just makes no sense fat
fast fasting like i'm just not going to
eat or i'm not going to do something i
enjoy
why
this just i mean literally just sounds
to us like the dumbest idea ever like
okay so god just wants me to be
miserable and that's somehow tied to
holiness
great you know we just it makes no sense
to us why because we don't understand
desire right we don't get that that's
like part of it
that it's about rightly order and when
we do that that like it's a powerful
practice of prioritizing and ordering
our desires is that you kind of tracking
um third and i'll close um prioritize
good desires don't just fight bad
desires
you know i think this could be a little
bit kind of the negative you know of
desire often leads to the the language
of evil desires which then we get in our
brains of like stop
don't
halt
cease you know and this is where we kind
of the mode we get that's sinful that's
evil that's wrong oh gosh you know we
get in that mode of very negative
instead of pursue the good
pursue the beautiful pursue the true
um this is the quote from anthony demelo
jesuit priest
he said nourish yourself on wholesome
food
good wholesome food i'm not talking
about actual food
i'm talking about sunsets
about nature
about a good movie about a good book
about enjoyable work about good company
and hopefully you will break your
addictions to those other
feelings
in other words
those disordered
desires
you pray with me
lord jesus
lord we are
um
swirling cauldrons of desire
we are pulled every which way
we feel so restless
we often feel so addicted
so controlled
by our impulses and urges and loves god
give us a taste for the good food that
is loving you and loving others
give us a taste for scriptures and
sunsets for coffee with a friend
in the silence of a walk in the woods
for chores that need doing
and a sense of your presence
as we do them
keep us from evil
make us a holy people
in the name of the father
and the son
and the holy spirit
amen
thank you
[Music]
please sing along with us everyone knows
worthy of all the praise you could ever
bring
worthy of every breath we could ever be
[Music]
jesus
jesus the only one who could ever say
[Music]
we could ever
only
there is no one like you
there is none
beside you
oh
show me
who you are
[Music]
worthy of all the praise we could ever
bring
[Music]
worthy of every breath we could ever
jesus name above every other name
jesus the only one who
worthy of every breath we could ever
[Music]
there is
show me
who you are
[Music]
there is
show me
who you
[Music]
to are
around me
[Music]
i
will build my life
upon your love
it is
[Music]
upon
i
will put my trust
in you
be
shaken
holy
there is no one like you
there is none
beside you
open up my eyes in
wonder
show me
who you are
[Music]
thanks you guys
and thank you for worshiping with us
tonight
um lots of things to think about and
take into the week ahead but again
remember you're not alone holiness is a
process it's not meant to be done in
isolation and it will get messy so just
know that and that's part of the process
and that's part of the grace of god to
keep coming back and asking god i
surrender again show me
help me and he is faithful to do that
don't forget about the volunteer
opportunity at five loves food pantry
this next saturday if you have any
questions or if you'd like to sign up
come see me or brett uh after the
service is over
and also if you are new uh visiting with
us tonight we have
cards on a little table outside this
door over here if you could write your
name and your contact information drop
it in the little box that's on the table
that way we can get in touch with you
this coming week
and also if you need prayer
come up and see me after service i would
be honored to pray with you
so if you wouldn't mind standing up
[Music]
and
let me share this benediction with you
as you go into the week ahead
and if you would like
open up your hands
to receive these words that are
true for you true for me true for the
world around us
you are a child of god
you
are a child
of god
this is true on your best day
and it's true on your worst day
so as you go into your week ahead with
its yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything in between
go
with the assurance that you are loved
you are worthy
and you are accepted just as you are
and go filled with god's holy spirit and
the desire to extend these same gifts
of love and unconditional grace to
everyone you come in contact with
this coming week
have a great week be blessed and we look
forward to seeing you back here next
sunday good night
[Music]
you